me menacer de toutes sortes de choses de
choses dégoûtantes qu'il allait me
balafrer ou visage pour que toute la
toute ma vie je pense à lui qu'il allait
pas qu'il allait pas se laver jusqu'à ce
qu'il me trouve pour que je sente sa
saleté sur moi toute ma vie
je m'appelle Lucie j'ai 20 ans et je
suis sur les réseaux sociaux plus sur
insta et Tik Tok je me suis lancée
là-dedans un peu au hasard au début je
pensais pas que ça allait marcher je
faisais des TikTok pour m'amuser et au
final ça a marché après je fais un peu
de tout je fais de l'humour bon sur
Instagram je pose des photos de moi mais
sinon sur Tik Tok je fais d'humour je
fais un peu des vidéos un peu
militantiste etc de temps en temps
faisait des études et je travaillais
sauf que les études j'ai un peu du mal
et pour le travail du coup avec
l'histoire après de moi harceleur j'ai
dû arrêter j'ai dû arrêter parce que je
travaille dans un magasin et en fait mon
harceleur il avait l'adresse donc il
disait qu'il allait venir etc et après
il venait donc j'ai dû arrêter ça a
commencé par un message sur les réseaux
sociaux il m'insultait rigoler etc et
moi je venais juste de commencer les
réseaux depuis quelques mois donc j'ai
essayé de répondre à tout le monde donc
j'ai répondu en rigolant et en fait
après même si par la suite j'ai pu
répondu il s'est jamais arrêté et après
il a commencé à marquer c'était un
message d'insultes un peu ridicule quoi
quand je lui ai répondu au début il m'a
encore
répondu mais après la conversation et
c'est fini sans problème il m'insultait
plus il avait l'air calmé et un mois
plus tard sans raison après avoir eu
aucun contact il m'envoie une vidéo de
Lyon en me disant oui viens tout de
suite à la gare du Nord on se voit comme
ça on s'était donné rendez-vous comme si
on se connaissait quoi et après en fait
il sait jamais arrêté non après je lui
ai plus répondu je lui ai répondu la
première fois après je lui ai plus
répondu et je bloquer ses comptes en
fait il recréé des comptes à l'infini
après Instagram ils l'ont interdit de
créer des comptes parce qu'il en avait
trop créé donc après ils m'ont envoyé
des mails il m'envoyer plein plein de
mails et je l'ignorais je faisais comme
si je les voyais pas au début c'était
des insultes ou une donnée des
rendez-vous il me disait qu'il voulait
me voir etc après il a commencé à partir
plus sur je vais dire et je vais te
battre ensuite il s'en est prêt à ma
famille il envoyait des messages à tous
mes amis toutes les personnes que je
connaissais ils l'ont envoyé des
messages et il est il est menacé pareil
je vais tous vous planter et demander ce
que je faisais pourquoi je répondais pas
j'en ai pas parlé tout de suite à ma
famille parce que au début vous ne le
prenez pas vraiment au sérieux je mets
de commencer les réseaux sociaux je me
disais bon c'est un message il va finir
par te lasser il est énervé dans une
semaine c'est fini je le bloque et puis
ça ça va passer sauf qu'en fait c'est
pas passé donc quand il a commencé à
s'en prendre à ma famille à mon petit
frère etc j'en ai parlé à ma famille
j'ai décidé d'aller porter plainte quand
il a parlé avec mon petit frère et qu'il
a commencé à menacer mon petit frère et
que il me disait qu'il rentrait dans des
écoles pour voir si j'étais etc et quand
je suis parti porter plainte j'étais
super mal reçue parce que le
cyber-harcèlement déjà c'est pas du tout
pris au sérieux mais là il y avait des
messages où il me disait tout ce que je
veux c'est ton gros cul et les policiers
c'est tout ce qu'il disait et il
rigolait et il me disait je note ça je
note ça et il notait que ça il y avait
des vidéos de vie avec un couteau etc il
voulait pas les regarder ensuite j'ai
envoyé des mails il me répondait pas ils
ouvraient pas les preuves à ce moment là
quand ça commence en fait c'était les
vacances d'été du coup j'étais chez mes
grands-parents donc j'étais pas en
France donc j'avais pas forcément de
problème je me disais bon ils m'embête
mais je reste un mois d'ici là il aura
fini sauf que je vois passé et je me
rends compte que je rentre dans une
semaine et là malgré que j'ai porté
plainte il se passerait donc là je me
dis il se rapproche de plus en plus de
là où j'habite il est vraiment déterminé
donc il va finir par trouver et je vais
rentrer là m'attendre devant chez moi
donc à ce moment-là je décide de
médiatiser l'affaire quand j'ai plus de
nouvelles du policier et que je lui
envoie un message une semaine après
avoir porté plainte et qui me dit qu'il
a toujours pas regardé mes preuves et
que il regardera plus tard le fait
d'avoir médiatisé ça a apporté du
positif et du négatif parce que ça a
tout de suite fait avancer les choses
mais après c'est un peu quelque chose
qu'on me reproche on dit qu'il faut
laisser la justice faire son travail la
police faire son travail mais j'avais
pas édition en fait parce que j'étais en
vacances dans un endroit où il y a rien
sans voiture donc je pouvais pas aller
dans un autre commissariat pour tes
plainte et j'étais un peu en détresse
parce que je rentrais chez moi je savais
qu'il allait m'attendre moi tout ce que
je voulais c'était qu'il soit arrêté
j'ai essayé d'aller porter plainte ça a
pas marché donc j'ai fait avec mes
moyens quand je suis rentrée il avait
été donc arrêté après que j'ai médiatisé
donc il a été arrêté il a pris deux ans
de sursis et quand je suis rentrée deux
jours plus tard il a essayé de
m'attraper je l'ai pas croisé en fait il
savait que j'allais rejoindre mon ami et
il a suivi mes amis en fait d'un
restaurant il les a suivi en voiture
sans se faire voir et quand il a vu
qu'il descendait dans une bouche de
métro il a cru qu'il venait me rejoindre
et donc il est descendu dans la bouche
de métro il l'a menace avec un couteau
sauf que c'est j'arrivais pas elle a été
arrêté une nouvelle fois et il a pris 8
mois de prison ferme il a fait trois
mois de prison il est sorti à sa sortie
une semaine après il a recommencé
directement sauf qu'il est encore plus
violent qu'avant il était encore plus
virulent il était beaucoup plus menaçant
et il me disait des choses beaucoup plus
poussées et bizarre il me détaillait
beaucoup plus ce qu'il allait faire
comment il allait me tuer comment il a
laissé prendre pour me violer ce qu'il
allait faire ma famille il a il menacé
mon petit frère de 14 ans de viol de le
séquestrer etc sauf que maintenant en
plus il avait mon nom de famille vu que
on avait eu un jouet ensemble mon
adresse précise et il me menaçait de
toutes sortes de choses de choses
dégoûtantes qu'il allait me battre ou
visage pour que toute la toute ma vie je
pense à lui qu'il allait pas qu'il
allait pas se laver jusqu'à ce qu'il
prouve pour que je sente sa saleté sur
moi toute ma vie à ce moment là je
retourne porter plaint donc cette
fois-ci il prend un enferme les
policiers ils étaient un peu plus
sérieux après c'était pas les mêmes
commissariat après j'ai quand même eu
des mauvaises expériences par exemple
avec une femme qui me disait mais
pourquoi tu es sur les réseaux sociaux
et qui me faisait mon procès à moi et me
poser que des questions sur moi au lieu
d'en poser sur lui pourquoi tu fais ça
tu cherches pas un peu et qui était
vraiment
inutile ça dépend vraiment des
commissariats j'ai eu des commissariats
où j'étais bien entendu et ça dépend
aussi des personnes mais après en
général c'est pas prêt au sérieux parce
que c'est du cyber-harcèlement de base
donc c'est pas dans la vraie vie que
quand j'ai médiatisé l'affaire j'ai
appris qu'il avait fait ça à plusieurs
autres filles et beaucoup et je pense
que alors d'aujourd'hui je ne sais pas
exactement le nom mais je dirais une
dizaine et qu'il y a eu des filles qui
va harceler pendant 7 ans des filles
mineures des filles qui l'a harcelé
pendant deux ans il y a eu d'autres
plaintes contre lui d'autres filles ou
ça a été classé ou alors il a été
condamné mais comme il le dit il est
toujours dehors en fait même s'il a une
condamnation il arrive toujours à rester
dehors le fait qu'il soit toujours
dehors j'arrive pas à le comprendre
parce que c'est pas comme si c'était
quelqu'un qui avait seulement quelque
chose contre moi il est pas dangereux
pour moi je pense qu'il est dangereux
pour toute la société que ce soit les
femmes ou même n'importe qui j'avais
reçu une vidéo d'un garçon qui était
mineur qui avait 16 ans qui l'avait
confondu dans la rue avec quelqu'un qui
avait menacé sur Internet et qu'il avait
sorti un couteau devant
le petit de 16 ans le menaçant etc alors
que c'était pas du tout lui je pense que
c'est un mec qui a rien à faire dehors
sa place elle est soit en prison ou soit
il faut qu'il ait des soins
psychiatriques pour essayer d'être un
peu arranger les choses si c'est
possible pour moi maintenant c'est
devenu une habitude et à chaque fois
qu'il est relâché je suis même plus
surprise en fait parce que je m'attends
plus rien malgré qu'il fasse des choses
graves qui respectent aucune obligation
il est toujours relâché et comme
lui-même il le vit il connaît la justice
il sera toujours dehors il est toujours
dehors on pensait une habitude pour moi
en fait de me faire harceler de devoir
déménager de faire attention quand je
sors de faire attention je pose et
d'être tout le temps sur le qui-vive
pour moi il ment parce qu'à chaque fois
à chaque fois qu'ils vont en garde à vue
en fait il ment même si il a été vu et
ment il est venu chez moi il a dit qu'il
était jamais venu il m'a envoyé des
messages il trouve toujours des excuses
oui mais je suis nue parce que j'étais
alcoolisée c'est pas ma faute c'est
jamais de sa faute en fait il n'assume
jamais rien il m'envoie des messages oui
non c'était pour que ça arrête d'être
médiatisé il me menace oui non on
m'avait menacé ce jour là c'est pour ça
que j'étais énervée donc à chaque fois
en fait il a des excuses bisous mais ça
passe tout le temps je sais pas s'il
pense que les messages ont été écrits
par quelqu'un d'autre mais vu qu'ils ont
été localisés au Maroc le doute lui
bénéficie donc il y a pas de preuve que
c'est lui vu qu'il y a pas son adresse
IP on peut pas le relier à ça donc ça on
soit je peux comprendre qu'il n'est pas
été condamné pour ça ce que je comprends
pas c'est que dans ce jugement là il y
avait aussi le fait qu'il m'a envoyé un
message directement à moi et il a avoué
que c'était lui parce que c'était un
message d'excuse sauf qu'ils m'envoie
des excuses à chaque fois qu'il fait
quelque chose après il recommence et
pour ça il a été relaxé quand même alors
que dans ces interdictions il y a bien
écrit qu'il a pas le droit de rentrer en
contact là il est libre il a pas de
bracelet il a rien du tout il fait ce
qu'il veut bah je me sens épuisée je me
sens un peu résignée en fait j'ai plus
de j'ai plus de solution parce que je
porte plainte ça fait rien en fait à
chaque fois même si il fait des choses
graves il vient chez moi il est quand
même relaxer alors que il a une
injonction d'éloignement envers moi il a
même pas le droit de venir dans mon
département et il vient devant chez moi
il est quand même relaxé donc j'ai juste
pu d'espoir en fait et je pense à
déménager parce que
il a tout le temps mon adresse en fait
il a eu mon adresse bah il a l'adresse
de chez mes parents grâce au jugement
quand j'habitais là-bas j'ai déménagé
après à Paris il a eu mon adresse à
Paris grâce au jugement qu'on a eu lui
et moi ensuite là maintenant j'ai
redéménagé j'ai donné mon adresse à
aucun jugement sur aucun papier pour
qu'il n'ait pas je me suis domicile chez
mon avocate pour qu'il est pas mon
adresse il a quand même réussi à la voir
puisqu'il a borné à côté de chez moi
apparemment donc je suis un peu résignée
je me dis qu'en fait la seule solution
c'est que c'est déménagé dans un autre
pays pour qu'il puisse pas venir parce
que même si je déménage en France s'il
arrive à avoir tout le temps mon adresse
bah ça me sert à rien mais la plupart
des gens ils disent de déménager ou ils
me disent que je devrais réagir moi sauf
que si je réagis moi c'est moi qui qui
au final aurait quelque chose de plus
grave que lui qui veut prendre plus que
lui donc je suis obligé d'attendre en
fait de toujours être dans l'attente
dans l'attente qu'un jour il se passe
quelque chose ou alors que il m'attrape
une bonne fois pour toute et que cette
fois-ci là en prison bah je suis obligé
de ressentir de la peur d'être toujours
faire attention au fait c'est juste
c'est juste invivable en fait de
toujours devoir faire attention à cause
d'une personne si je poste ça est-ce
qu'il va savoir où je suis si il voit un
petit bout de sentiment est-ce que il
est capable de reconnaître si si je vais
chez mes parents est-ce que peut-être il
va venir et en fait de juste me demander
quand est-ce qu'il va être condamné
parce que il rentre il a des obligations
il respecte pas il doit suivre une
formation inhi il va pas il a une
injonction d'éloignement vers moi il
vient chez mes parents il est relaxé
parce qu'il est alcoolisé alors que on
ne connaissait pas du tout ces
intentions s'il m'avait eu devant lui
qu'est-ce qu'il aurait fait il m'envoie
des messages alors qu'il a pas le droit
d'être en contact avec moi il est relax
il est relaxé il me menace il y a aucune
poursuite au téléphone de la prison
quand il était encore en prison il m'a
menacé il y a aucune poursuite ils l'ont
laissé sortir alors qu'il menait assez
ça concerne de l'insertion enfin ça se
voyait clairement qu'il n'était pas prêt
à sortir et que c'était toujours un
danger mais ils l'ont quand même laissé
sortir donc je me demande en fait quand
est-ce qu'il va être condamné pour moi
maintenant la seule façon qu'il soit
condamné c'est qu'il s'en prenne
directement à moi soit qui m'adresse qui
est soit qui m'agresse ou soit qui me
tue
oui je suis en colère pour les décisions
qui ont été prises le fait qu'il ait
relaxé alors qu'il soit venu chez moi ça
c'est vraiment la décision que j'ai le
moins comprise parce que je pense que
pire à part m'agresser il peut pas le
faire en fait il est venu chez moi il a
fait deux heures de route pour venir
chez moi donc je pense que l'alcool au
bout de deux heures il s'était un peu
quand même dissipé qu'il aurait pu
rentrer chez lui ou avoir une prise de
conscience ou j'en sais rien mais non il
est venu chez moi il a attendu il a
essayé de rentrer à trois reprises et il
s'est fait attrapé à trois reprises il a
appelé mon père pour qu'il vienne et
s'il m'avait eu devant lui je pense que
il aurait réagi plus agressivement et il
aurait pu m'agresser mais vu qu'il y a
chaque fois en fait il a de la il a la
chance de pas me croiser de soi avoir
mon ami le menacer qu'un couteau ou
avoir mon père
des messages à une fille en disant qu'il
allait me tuer qu'il allait me tuer
toutes les deux qui a une séquestrer et
il y a eu la fois où du coup il a essayé
de rentrer chez moi et il a rien eu non
plus le dernier contact que j'ai eu avec
lui c'était à peu près un mois et demi
avant qu'il soit en détention provisoire
et du coup qu'il soit relaxé c'est son
message d'excuse oui s'excuse pour que
ça arrête d'être médiatisé et que lui ne
se fasse pas harceler je lui ai pas
répondu je l'ai bloqué directement et
j'ai pris une capture d'écran et depuis
plus rien en fait il m'envoie plus de
messages du tout parce qu'il sait qu'à
chaque fois qu'il m'envoie un message il
rentre en prison si c'est un peu
menaçant il rentre en prison si vous
êtes harcelé tout ce que je peux vous
conseiller c'est de porter plainte même
si bon ça mène pas toujours à quelque
chose et aussi de faire attention à ce
que vous postez sur les réseaux sociaux
de pas montrer vos habitudes vraiment
même si on se dit ça arrive qu'aux
autres moi c'est ce que je me disais en
commençant les réseaux sociaux ça fait
que quatre mois que je suis là ça va pas
m'arriver je suis pas super connue mais
non ça arrive pas qu'aux autres donc ne
montrais pas vous habitez et ce que je
voudrais dire à la justice je voudrais
demander en fait qu'est-ce qu'ils
attendent pour le condamner je peux
comprendre la condamnation où ils ont
pas assez de preuves pour le condamner
mais les autres
je ne comprends pas en fait pourquoi il
a été relaxé pour des faits où il est
rentré chez moi etc et je me demande en
fait ce qu'ils attendent s'ils attendent
peut-être ma mort ou que je me fasse
agresser et si je meurs il faudra pas
dire en fait que ou qu'ils étaient pas
au courant et que ils sont désolé